how did you prepare for this event we
know it's a very prestigious event what
was your training routine coming into
this map i've been studying chess
a lot
since the epidemic started
and basically u.s senior role is in my
mind
this is like the main goal
basically for the last six months uh i'm
thinking about this while i'm studying
chess i didn't have much time to prepare
because
i just came from europe where i played
for u.s
national team
senior team in the world championship as
always nothing changed i
played some tournaments before so that
to work for to warm up
to be ready of course some some
preparation
like all this
this is a professional professional life
of just play something nothing special
for this
event i was kind of trying to convince
my
managers and my my wife and my family
that that's something that you know i
should be doing and once they got on
board i am basically just
trying to look up who is going to play
and basically
find
something to encourage myself that i can
i can fight those people basically
playing non-stop it's a little bit
different tactic that i used to so
i just got back from italy and i played
for the us team at the world seniors and
then i played the world open right after
that
so basically i played for the last three
weeks non-stop okay so getting back
reviewing what's uh the top games in the
world what the opening strategies are
uh when i
see what colors i have against my
opponent then i'll get to spend some
time trying to work out how the openings
are gonna go there nothing special you
know just as usual we watch the games
and trying to analyze and train to think
um you know
that's it nothing unusual you know the
main thing is i think in these
tournaments you want to be as large as
possible at all times you know could go
four or five hours of hard intense
concentration and i found the worst
thing you can do and i've done this so
many times is to
cram for
big games
staying up till four in the morning you
know over preparing and just wearing
yourself out i'll try to avoid that this
time well you know life gets in the way
of things so i've been doing a lot of
things
you know i'm not a full-time
professional player anymore so um you
know maybe i have a little catch up to
do but i think that's probably true for
most of the players
so i i think it really comes down to you
know which which player you know summons
up the energy to fight in the in the in
the fourth hour it remains to be seen
but whether what i have done was
actually what i was supposed to be doing
but uh
let's uh
let's not speak too much about it for
now
[Music]
you